it's ridiculous you know it did not come
from chinese food it came from
it's a zoonotic disease david say came
to the uk from hong kong as a young
child
proudly british he's built a successful
career
as an actor writer and director
there are still so many others who are
suffering
he's experienced his share of racist
abuse over the years
but says it's nothing compared to what's
happening now with coronavirus
if you listen to these dangerous
politicians or far-right people
who are scapegoating others
what that will lead to is fascism and
nazism you know we've got to oppose it
police forces across the country told us
of 267
recorded offenses in the first three
months of this year
compared to 375 for the whole of 2019.
the metropolitan police recorded 63
offenses
a three-fold increase on the same period
last year
they included the appalling assault on
singaporean student
jonathan mock attacked on oxford street
michael chu studies at university in
sheffield
he's also been abused and threatened
with assault
we were literally just sat at the
traffic lights and he started just
giving me all of this abuse and
he was threatening to come and uh
basically just
put me in hospital in other words and uh
it was definitely unexpected and it was
i was quite shocked
these chinese students at southampton
university
were confronted by another group
accusing them of spreading the virus
long before the lockdown chinese and
asian businesses here
were seeing a sharp drop in trade as
fear and misunderstanding
was stoked by internet conspiracies and
with the finger of blame being pointed
at the chinese
by the world's most powerful leader the
u.s president
well that only exacerbates the problem
although a three-fold increase in hate
crime is worrying enough
those we've spoken to feared the numbers
being verbally abused and assaulted
will rise even more sharply in the weeks
ahead
as the lockdown is lifted mark white sky
news